the problem of identifying deep fakes
May soon be a thing of the past Intel
has created the fake catcher neural
network which can spot a deep fake in
real time with 96 accuracy previously in
order to check for a deep fake you
either needed to know exactly who to
look out for or upload the Deep fake to
a third-party service it's pretty time
consuming and inconvenient fake Catcher
from Intel analyzes the geometry of the
face records changes in skin tones and
determines the accuracy of the image in
a fraction of a second for example this
is how the face of a living person looks
to a neural network and this is what a
deep fake looks like it's not yet clear
how the AI will determine the
authenticity of a video with a face in
profile or a video with poor lighting
but in any case if social networks and
news portals team up with fake catcher
it will reduce the criminal potential of
deep fakes and the online jungle will
become a little safer leave a like if
you want even more videos about deep
fakes